je m'appelle david eldar donc j'ai 44
ans nouvellement concis départementale
donc sur le canton saint denis 11
cantons 3
c'est vraiment un conte est aussi que
que j'affectionne parce que je suis élu
à bellepierre et donc à bellepierre où
j'ai grandi je suis partie au lycée de
bellepierre je passais au collège au bas
de la rivière l'école primaire et donc
c'est vraiment un attachement ce secteur
que je connais très bien
[Musique]
toujours combattu toutes les injustices
et les inégalités
donc ce qui m'emmenait à s'engager
politiquement et ce département donc
concrètement qu'est ce que je suis au
département donc moi je suis prise en
commission éducation culture sport et
mobilité donc qui touche l'ensemble des
collèges qui touche cette mobilité les
jeunes éducation et bien sûr à travers à
ça c'est de faire en sorte que cette que
ce collage là où nos marmailles on va
dire se construisent et il faut
construire la réunion de demain donc les
aider à préparer aux tours de 2 bien sûr
ces enjeux qui sont importants pour
qu'on puisse avoir des jeunes prêts à
affronter les enjeux de demain
département des jeunes réunionnais en
forme bien sûr au delà de cette présence
de commissions je suis sur notre
territoire et sur partout la réunion il
ya quelque chose quand même qui me tient
vraiment à coeur en tout cas aborder
comme projet on va dire un peu phare de
cette mandature c'est les aidants
familiaux les aidants familiaux souvent
au delà de l'aspect officiel de ce qui
existe il ya aussi des aidants familiaux
qui sont invisibles qui ne sont pas
connus une nièce attend une tante qui
sont là pour aider des personnes âgées
isolées des personnes handicapées les
familles où j'ai rencontré avec des
enfants qui sont touchés par l'autisme
ou voir d'autres formes de handicap
s'inquiètent du devenir leurs enfants si
demain ils ne sont plus on va dire parmi
nous et donc toutes ces questions nous
interroge nous devrons aussi nous
adapter en fonction des évolutions de la
société de demain est de faire en sorte
qu'on puisse se tenir prêts là
maintenant et de commencer vraiment
d'aller plus loin sur ce sujet parce que
c'est vraiment un sujet baky qui aussi
rencontré de notre culture is la réunion
de faire en sorte qu'on puisse s'occuper
de nos aînés et de ceux qui peuvent pas
pour bâtir s'occuper du salé être
autonome
[Musique]
le débordement c'est pour moi c'est la
famille en général c'est la famille à
travers toutes ses délégations à travers
toutes ces thématiques toutes ces aides
qu'elles apportent des aides sociales
aux plus démunis aux plus faibles aux
personnes âgées enfin pour moi c'est la
famille dans son ensemble et c'est vrai
que le département avec les moyens mis à
disposition de la population doit
effectivement être dans cette proximité
se déplacer vers ces personnes qui
furent besoin nous le département doit
être ancrée dans nos territoires chaque
territoire identité chaque commune à son
identité et je crois que vraiment le
département les réunionnais auront un
gagnant tout à ce mandat à retrouver est
en tout cas poursuivre un département au
plus proche de ses administrés